other witnesses have recently shared  their recollection of overhearing this  call for the most part I have no reason  to doubt their accounts it's true that  the President speaks loudly at times and  it's also true I think we primarily  discussed ASAP Rocky it's true that the  president likes to use colorful language  anyone who has met with him at for any  reasonable amount of time knows this  well I cannot remember the precise  details again the White House has not  allowed me to see any readouts of that  call and the July 26 call did not strike  me as significant at the time actually  actually I would have been more  surprised if President Trump had not  mentioned investigations particularly  given what we were hearing from mr.  Giuliani about the president's concerns